la riposte s'organise contre le colis de
10,9 début janvier les premiers centres
de vaccination ouvrent dans le
département comme à saint quentin en
yvelines où le vélodrome se transforme
progressivement en vaccinodromes des
centres et qu'ils seront même mobile
levac six bus du conseil départemental
sillonne les routes pour aller au
contact des habitants des zones rurales
la campagne se veut progressive les
pharmacies se joignent à l'effort avec
un peu de retard dû à la suspension
temporaire du vaccin astrazeneca les
yvelinois qui vivent au rythme des
mesures sanitaires du gouvernement un
couvre-feu passant à 18 heures des
grands centres commerciaux fermés
notamment à des visites 2 ou encore 3e
confinement décrété au printemps pour
quatre semaines pendant ce temps là les
restaurants bars ou encore lieux
culturels restent fermés
le tribunal administratif de versailles
annulé les élections municipales de 2020
à trappes en cause le rejet des comptes
de campagne du maire élu ali rabais la
décision sera confirmée en août par le
conseil d'état les trappistes revoteront
en octobre trappe victime de
l'emballement médiatique après les
propos de didier lemaire le professeur
de philosophie au lycée de la plaine de
neauphle parle d'une ville
définitivement perdue est sous emprise
islamiste menace et il quittera
l'éducation nationale pour contrer la
polémique le rappeur saint quentinois
kurt assortira le morceau trappe qui
donne une image positive de la ville
[Musique]
renault lance arnaud lucioles usine de
flins sur seine sera spécialisé dans
l'économie circulaire le technocentre de
guyancourt accueillir à la software et
publics pour penser avec d'autres
entreprises le véhicule de demain c'est
l'une des mesures du grenelle des
violences conjugales le bracelet anti
rapprochement est déployée dans les
yvelines une convention a été signée au
tribunal judiciaire de versailles le
latmos installé à vue en cours au coeur
de l'actualité spatiale lancement de son
anneau satellite us qu sade pour
observer le soleil et la terre le
laboratoire a également développé
l'outil super calme du rover
persévérance qui va collecter des
échantillons de la planète mars côté
sport le pistard grégory baugé prend sa
retraite celle yvelinois tire sa
révérence après neuf titres de champion
du monde et quatre médailles olympiques
la performance de louis burton le
skipper de rambouillet termine 3e du
vendée globe sur son bateau bureau
vallée et pour la douzième année
consécutive le par eni s'est élancé des
yvelines la course cycliste a démarré de
saint cyr l'école avant de prendre le
départ le lendemain de la petite commune
doit ville sur mansion
enfin ils nous ont quittés au premier
semestre 2021 jean gombert maire de bois
d'arcy entre 89 et 95 le sergent even
wind tués au mali était né à trappes
marielle de sarnez eurodéputés d'île de
france pendant 17 ans la comédienne
catherine rich dont les obsèques se sont
déroulées à orgeval le sculpteur gérard
amon auteur de nombreuses oeuvres à
maurepas et olivier dassault fondateur
de génération entreprise